what is a youpreneur a youpreneur is
somebody
who genuinely builds a business based
around their expertise okay so it is the
content creator it is the professional
speaker or the author or the educator
it's somebody who you know when I look
at our our programs at yo.com I look at
all the different levels that people
come into some people are right at the
beginning of their Journeys uh some
people are more you know more advanced
more further along in that Journey
and I always say that no matter what
where you're at in your development as a
upur you're exactly where you need to be
right now we can help you get to the
next step and the next and the next uh
but but a uper at the very core is
somebody who who is at least at the very
least deems themselves who has a certain
amount of expertise and what they do and
how they do
[Music]
it